devops is a relatively new practice
as the name suggests devops consists of
two parts development and it operations
we can think of devops as a natural
extension of agile because they are
based on similar principles
it aims to shorten the system's
development life cycle and provide
continuous delivery with high software
quality
devops speeds up the process by means of
developing and testing much smaller
chunks of code and then deploying them
continuously into production what makes
devops great is that we can release more
often test more precisely and receive
feedback from production on the go
eventually we are delivering more value
to our customers more often the main
principles of devops are explained by
the cams model which was created by
damon edwards and john willis
cms stands for culture automation
measurement and sharing let's look at
these four devops principles in detail
in order to understand what each entails
principle 1
culture
even though we use some pretty advanced
technology and tools and devops
at the core of what we're trying to
solve are problems related to people and
business
culture is defined by the interaction of
people in groups and is driven by
behavior substantial communication
improvement can result when there is a
mutual understanding of others and their
goals and responsibilities
so in order to get all the benefits of
devops first we need to bridge the gap
between development quality assurance
and operations by setting the right
culture traditional information
technology business models split
developers and i t operations into two
distinct groups
devops culture principle on the other
hand suggests having shared
responsibilities between development and
i.t operations teams this guarantees
that the development team will be
involved in software maintenance on the
production while understanding
deployment requirements better at the
same time the it operations team can
have a better grasp on the functional
needs of a system
another important aspect of culture
principle is that devops is centered
around a business oriented mindset of
all team members
basically we are removing any silos and
communication between the team members
and stakeholders that gives us a better
understanding of business objectives and
ensures that each team member takes
personal responsibility for the
product's success
changing the business culture by sharing
responsibility in getting development
and i t operations teams on the same
page is a major goal of devops principle
2
automation
we all know that automation can save
time effort and money
the automation principle focuses on
people and processes and not just tools
the backbone of devops is the practices
of continuous delivery and continuous
integration
this implies that we are constantly
pushing the code to our testing and
staging environments as well as deliver
it to production
unlike traditional deployment of large
chunks of code and devops we can deploy
each time there is a production ready
bit of code
frequent updates make it vital to run
tests faster and monitor code on
production which leads us to the general
idea of automating the whole pipeline
in devops this is accomplished by
creating pipelines that perform code
testing integration deployment
monitoring and feedback exchange
automatically
principle three
measurement using measurements will help
in determining if progress is being made
in the intended direction
the automation of a feedback loop
provides valuable insights about the
features deployed on production
as we are dealing with the smaller
chunks of code the culprits are much
easier to spot and fix
devops measurement principle encourages
you to see the forest from the trees by
taking a look at the entire operation
and assessing it as a whole and not just
focusing on small parts
devops teams should develop and track
certain key metrics in order to help
check their systems
these metrics can include things like
lead time the time it takes to implement
test and deploy code deployment
frequency change failure rate average
time to recovery average time between
failures and defect escape rate
overall by measuring various key
performance indicators the team should
strive to continuously improve their
systems and i t operations
principle 4 sharing
sharing is caring
this phrase explains the dev ops
philosophy better than anything else as
it highlights the importance of
collaboration
it is crucial to share feedback best
practices and knowledge among teams
since this promotes transparency creates
collective intelligence and eliminates
constraints
devops processes similar to agile and
scrum place a very high premium on
transparency and openness when everyone
on the team is open this helps in
building trust and fun working
environment
transparency ensures that every team
member can see and measure the progress
and work towards a common goal
besides spreading knowledge helps to
tighten feedback loops and enables the
organization to continuously improve
this collective intelligence makes the
team a more efficient unit and allows it
to become greater than just the sum of
its parts
given the cam's model is now clear that
the pure automation component of the
build and delivery chain is only a small
part of devops in reality devops is not
just an automation tool but way more
than that
it is a culture and a state of mind
which uses the same concepts as agility
and lean principles
if you found this video useful i would
appreciate it if you smash the like
button also make sure to subscribe to
the coding tech channel and click on the
notification bell enjoy the rest of your
day